مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه الانسانيه
الخاصه بتداعيات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
وفيها نناقش مطالبه منظمات حقوقيه بفتح
تحقيق عاجل في المعامله اللا انسانيه
والاخفاء القصري من قبل جيش الاحتلال
للمعتقلين الفلسطينيين في غزه اذ قالت
منظمه العفو الدوليه انها قلقه بشان مصير
ومكان وجود فلسطيني القطاع الذين تحتجزهم
قوه الاحتلال واشارت الى ان مصيرهم ما زال
مجهولا لمناقشه هذا الموضوع سيكون معنا
الدكتور تريستينو
مارينو استاذ القانون الدولي بجامعه
ليفربول وعضو الفريق القانوني لضحايا حرب
غزه امام المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه قبل الدخول في هذا النقاش في
الحوار نذكر بحصي الشهداء جراء الحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه اذا ارتفع عدد
ضحايا العدوان الاسرائيلي الى اكثر من 200
ال شهيد بحسب المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي في
قطاع غزه والجرحى بلغ او ارتفع الى
52600 منذ السابع من اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي بينما 8000 طفل اضافه الى
امراه نذكر بالمساعدات التي دخلت الى قطاع
غزه حتى اليوم اذ تقول اخر احصائيه لهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني ان عدد الشاحنات التي
دخل القطاع عبر معبر رفح بلغ
4300 شاحنه في الفتره بين الحادي والعش من
اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي وال 16 عشر من
ديسمبر كانون الاول الجاري وكان يدخل
القطاع نحو 500 شاحنه يوميا قبل الحرب
التي يشنها الجيش الاسرائيلي على غزه منذ
السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي اذا طالبت منظمات حقوقيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي بالكشف عن مصير المعتقلين من
قطاع غزه والافراج عنهم وحذرت من تعرضهم
للتعذيب والمعامله المهينه وكان المرصد
الاورو متوسط لحقوق الانسان وثق قيام
الجيش الاسرائيلي بحملات اعتقال عشوائيه
طالت اكثر من 1200 مدني فلسطيني من مناطق
مختلفه من قطاع غزه عقب اقتحامه منازل
سكنيه ومدارس ومراكز ايوا هذا وكانت
صحيفتها اريتس اشارت الى ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يحتجز معتقلي من قطاع غزه في
معسكر بمنطقه بئر السبع وهم معصوب الاعين
ومقيد الايدي لفترات طويله وكشفت الصحيفه
ان عددا منهم توفوا داخل المعتقل دون
معرفه عددهم بشكل دقيق وعن ظروف وفاتهم
نستقبل الان اذا ضيفنا من ليفربول الدكتور
تريستينو مارينيو استاذ القانون الدولي
بجامعه ليفربول وعضو الفريق قانوني لضحايا
حرب غزه امام المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
دكتور تريستينو فيما يتعلق بمن يوصفون
بانهم اسرى فلسطينيون تم اختطافهم واخذهم
من قطاع غزه وتم الزج بهم في معتقلات في
صحراء النقب تحديدا في بئر السبعه ما
التوصيف القانوني
لهؤلاء بدايه شكرا على الاستضافه الليله
القانون الدولي وخاصه القانون الدولي
الانساني وقانون حقوق الانسان حقوق
الانسان تطبق عندما يكون هنالك صراعات مثل
الصراع ضد قطاع غزه هذا الامر يوفر حمايه
للافراد ليس فقط للمدنيين لكن حتى
للمقاتلين الذين يتم
اعتقالهم اذا الحمايه تمنع اي شكل من
التعذيب او من سوء المعامله او اي شكل من
نزع انسانيه الافراد المدنيين والمقاتلين
وهو يمنع ايضا الاختفاء القصري في بعض
الاحيان من الواضح ان القانون الدولي
الانساني وقانون حقوق الانسان
يمنع اي خرق لحقوق الخاصه بحياه الافراد
ما نراقبه ونشاهده الان نراقب المدنيين في
غزه وهذه الممارسات التي تمارس ضدهم هو هي
خروق واضحه للقانون الدولي
والذي تضع المسؤوليه على السلطات
الاسرائيليه وعلى الدوله الاسرائيليه وهي
في نفس الوقت ترقى الى جرائم حرب وجرائم
ضد
الانسانيه وهي تمثل خرقا
ل فقره التعذيب يضا الاختفاء القصري ليس
هنالك ايضا في اطار الصراعات المسلحه لا
يمكن السلطات الاسرائيلي
هذه دكتور تريستينو
دكتور تريستينو ولكن حتى كل ما نعرفه حتى
الان حتى الان لا بيان رسمي من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي لا يتكلم عن اعدادهم ولا مكان
اعتقالهم ولا ظروف اعتقالهم كل ما نعرفه
ما قالته صحيفه اريتس او ما نقل عن بعض
الشهادات من بعض العائدين من سكان غزه من
هذه المعتقلات وبالتالي ايضا ما المسؤوليه
القانونيه على الجيش الاسرائيلي فيما
يتعلق بمعرفه بصير هؤلاء واعدادهم ومن
يكونوا اذا مره اخرى يجب على بدايه
ان ييكون هنالك توجيه تهم قبل ان يك امام
المحاكم لكن هذا الامر لن يحدث امام
المحاكم الاسرائيليه هنالك تاكيد على
تقرير منظمه العفو الدوليه على مساله
التحقيق وايضا وهذا على عكس ما تمارسه
السلطات الاسرائيليه السؤال هو من الذي
سيقوم بالتحقيق هذه التحقيق ضد هذه
الممارسات التي تمارسها قوات الاحتلال على
المستوى الدولي هنالك
هيئتان لجنه التحقيق وايضا لجنه وايضا
مكتب المدعي العام في المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه بعض مما سجل من شهادات كما ذكرت
العائدين من بعض المخطوفين او الاسرى
الاسرائيليين الذين عادوا الى قطاع غزه
تكلموا على ان بعضا من زملائهم في
المعتقلات الاسرائيليه قد ماتوا وان اتكلم
عن من كانوا على سبيل المثال في صحراء
النقب ماتوا تحت التعذيب او بالاهمال انهم
بقوا لفترات طويله جدا لايام وهم معصب
الاعين وكذلك تم تجريدهم من ثيابهم ما
الذي يقوله القانون الدولي حتى عندما
يتعلق الامر
باسرى جنود قبل ان يكونوا
مدنيين اذا كما ذكرت سابقا هذه المزاعم
بامكانها ان ترقى الى خرق واضح للقانون
الدولي وفي هذه الحاله هذه
الخروقات هي حق تمنع حق الحياه و
لا لا يمكن ان تخرق حتى في سياق الصراعات
المسلحه بالتاكيد هذه المزاعم يجب ان يتم
تحقيق بها من قبل لجنه مستقله لكن ما
نعرفه في الضفه الغربيه ايضا ان السلطات
الاسرائيليه تمارسوا بعض الممارسات التي
ترقى الى التعذيب والى المعاملات غير
الانسانيه للمحتجزين وهي تمنع المحتجزين
الفلسطينين من حقوقهم الاساسيه اكثر هنالك
اكثر من 4000 محتجز فلسطيني بدون توجيه اي
تهم لهم وايضا يتم عرضهم على محاكم عسكريه
في بعض الاحيان هذه ممارسات ممنهجه
وممارسات واسعه النطاق من قبل السلطات
الاسرائيليه لخرق الحقوق
للمعتقلين الفلسطينين وهذا يمثل ايضا يجب
على المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ان تتدخل
لان هذا الامر قد يرقى الى جرائم دوليه
ومن غير الم المدعي العام
عندما
شرامه حول هذا الامر ضيفي من ليفربول
الدكتور تريستينو مارينو استاذ القانون
الدولي بجامعه ليفربول وعضو الفريق
القانوني لضحايا حرب غزه امام المحكمه
الجنائيه
الدوليه ختم هذه النافذه الانسانيه الخاصه
بتداعيات حرب حرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه